thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air which now comes
with nebula for free get 40% off of both
with a documentary distancing discount
link in the description finally at the
end of their rope
the police shoot more gas munitions
through every window in the house to
flush secant out something has to be
done and fast what would you do if you
lost your home not because of fire or
flood or other horrifying natural
disaster what would you do if your home
was taken and destroyed by the very
people you trust it to protect you
the police in your own community for
most of us our home is our most valuable
possession not only in terms of monetary
value but also regarding our own
personal safety and security and don't
forget about the sentimental bond many
of us feel with our homes we spend most
of our time at home relaxing with loved
ones playing with our kids and
celebrating family occasions so is it
ever ok for the government to just
destroy our homes without notice in the
name of public good imagine that while
you're out with your family enjoying a
nice day of shopping the local police
blow up your house reducing your
sanctuary to rubble all in order to
catch your felon frightening right but
it can happen and it did happen to one
family in Colorado in 2015
once the initial shock of the family
wore off they wondered will the
government compensate us for the total
destruction of our home
well that's the question that we must
answer in the case of the house the
police blew up submitted for your jude
occasion summertime 2015 a beautiful
cloudless day in greenwood village just
south of Denver Colorado the happy
family of Leigh oelek lives an idyllic
suburban life in their comfortable 2,000
square foot two-story home there a busy
working group patriarch Leo and his wife
their son John and his young family the
week's are rushed and seemed to fly by
but they get to relax just a little on
the weekends as it is for many Americans
their house is their prized possession
they take great pride in its appearance
and on this particular day the Lexx are
planning a family outing with a home in
mind as luck would have it the family
sets off on a fun day of shopping for
the home renovation they're particularly
excited because they've been saving for
this home makeover project for more than
two years
first they plan to visit a flooring
store to choose some new hardwood floors
then they're headed to the home center
to pick up a few odds and ends the only
one not excited for this big weekend
shopping trip is the family's
nine-year-old son he decides to stay
back and take care of the Lexx - hunting
dogs meanwhile on the other side of town
another man is planning a very different
kind of day in a local Walmart the floor
manager notices a disheveled customer
doesn't seem to quite fit in wandering
in the electronics department the
customer 1 Robert JC can't see can't
thinks no one is looking and he begins
pocketing small electronics and other
items from the store but what he doesn't
realize is that his every move is being
caught on the store's surveillance
cameras the floor manager quickly calls
the police who arrived just a few
minutes later as the officers make their
way into the building see can't realizes
the jig is up he hastily ducks behind a
display cases and bolts for the exit
luckily for Seacat he briefly evades the
police and escapes from the Walmart
property but without a plan
he just starts running of course the
Lexx are blissfully unaware of secant
the botched robbery and the harrowing
chase unfolding on the other side of
town as they picture pieces of new
furniture and other decorative items in
their home the luck family happily
continue discussing furniture options as
they finished shopping they're looking
forward to taking all of their new
furnishings to their home in Greenwood
Village but Seacat manages to jump into
his beat-up old pickup truck and speeds
away from Walmart but he doesn't get
very far the old pickup which has never
been very reliable quickly stalls see
can't abandons the vehicle and tries to
evade police on foot
frantically scurrying around the
neighborhood while looking for cover
he comes upon the Lexx house where all
is peaceful luck heard Lee approaches
the side of the house which luckily for
him is obscured by trees so he picks up
a rock takes one deep breath and breaks
the window little does he know he has
just triggered a silent alarm back at
the Walmart one of the witnesses tells
the police that seek hat is armed
lending new gravity to the chase more
officers are immediately dispatched to
deal with a potentially violent criminal
the likes meanwhile are still completely
unaware of the break-in at home and that
their house alarm has been triggered
don't forget their 9 year old son is at
home alone but as far as they know they
have no reason to fear for his safety
so the adult family members stop for a
quick meal before they had at home but
at approximately 2:00 p.m. the Greenwood
village police respond to the alarm
triggered at the lek home see cat has
unlawfully entered in his efforts to
flee police luckily the luck family's
boy hears the ruckus in the garage
terrified the child goes straight to the
front door and escapes from the would-be
burglar
fortunately see cats so engrossed in
trying to steal one of the family cars
from the garage that the boys safely
sneaks away but the dogs the young son
stayed home to watch are still in the
backyard after a further investigation
the police learned that this would be
shoplifter actually has a record and a
history of violence as an officer
cautiously pulls up to the Lexx house
and lazily exits his squad car bullets
from inside blast through the garage
door one of the bullets pings the police
car missing the officer by inches that
changes everything
if si can is willing to open fire on the
police what else is he capable of the
police begin to realize just how
dangerous this situation has become at
this point the Lexx still have no idea
of the potentially deadly situation
raveling at their home but it won't be
long before they find out their planned
renovation is going to be on a scale
they never imagined the cops on the
scene immediately report the high-risk
situation requesting back-up
an emergency response team and a crisis
negotiations team shortly after that
call a dispatch commander Dustin Varney
arrives on the scene and takes command
the situation escalates fast so
commander Varney finally orders that Leo
luck be contacted with a warning to stay
away the news that his home is the scene
of a potentially explosive standoff as a
shock to Leo's life it turns out that
see cat is wanted on several felony
warrants and is a known drug dealer
and now he's in the Lexx family house
armed and as far as the police note may
be under the influence guns and drugs a
combination that makes the response team
very nervous
Varney being the man in charge starts
making decisions to secure the scene he
has the home surrounded in sets of
tactical command posts then burning
directs the crisis negotiations team to
take over and try to reason with Seacat
a tall order given C Kats instability
the acts of violence he's already
committed still the negotiators have to
try tipping them off a grueling hours
long negotiation and as the afternoon
wanes and secant speaks with negotiators
he keeps hinting that he might surrender
voluntarily the
keeps telling the cops things like I'll
come out but I just want more time I
don't want to hurt anyone and I'm almost
ready to come out
but when Barney gives Seacat one last
chance to come out of the Lexx home
peacefully he refuses so the police turn
off his cell phone and move on to the
next much more drastic step a few
minutes after 7 p.m.
cold gas munitions are deployed through
the first-floor window in an effort to
smoke seek an out
but when secant remains inside barney
surmises he must be holed up on the
second floor which means he also has the
tactical advantage if the police go in
after him they could get shot Barney
makes more quick decisions something has
to be done and fast but all this time
the lex family dogs have been in the
back yard at the sound of the first hole
blown into the wall one of the dogs
escapes while the other pooch is still
potentially in harm's way the lex notify
police that the dogs are there but the
cops assured elect family that their
pets will be fine meanwhile varney has
to try something else
to neutralize CCAP still hoping the
burglar will tell the police he'll
surrender peacefully barney decides to
send in a robot with a throw phone to
open up lines of communication without
allowing secant to contact a third
parties of course after all the gas
grenades it's anybody's guess whether or
not secant will be willing to cooperate
getting to throw phone into the house in
the first place is hard enough but the
robot has to enter the house to get
there to do so police decide to
literally blow the doors off the luck
house to make way for the robot to get
in they use a Bearcat armored vehicle
and Explosives to create an entry point
for the tactical team in the robot which
they send in with the phone more than
three hours later at approximately 10:40
p.m. the SWAT team enters the residence
on the first floor an attempt to reach
the second floor one calculated move at
a time but secant has other plans and
from the second floor opens fire on them
the team quickly pulls back exiting the
home barney is losing patience while the
Leck family is being kept at a distance
unable to see the chaos in their own
house
despite the continuous ringing of the
throw phone and announcements over the
loudspeaker officers outside can hear
see can't reloading his weapon four more
hours crawl by and seek hat never comes
out of hiding
nor answers the phone the exhausting
night bleeds into the grim morning at
about 5:00 a.m.
Varney approves the launch of another
exploding device this time aimed at the
east side of the garage in an effort to
limit see cats movements the homeowners
still have no clue about what's
happening to their own house finally at
the end of their rope the police shoot
more gas munitions through every window
in the house to flush secant out they
blow up virtually every door and every
window all the while they continue
attempting to negotiate but nothing
works
finally Varney takes out his final steps
measures that will seal the tragic fate
of the Lex family house Varney orders
the Bearcat to open up holes in the back
of the residence
Barney's exact instructions are take as
much of the building is needed without
making the roof fall in Barney's plan
has three goals one to locate CCAP
within a home two to prevent him from
being able to ambush officers sent in
after him and three to create gun ports
so snipers could if necessary shoot into
the residence from a distance and so the
police remotely control the Bearcat and
begin bulldozing the house
piece by piece wall by wall they start
to demolish the walls tear down the
doors and open up sight lines the Lexx
are about to get that open-concept house
they'd always wanted with the
destruction complete Varney orders a
tactical team to arrest secant by all
means necessary the SWAT team rams
through the shell of the house runs up
the stairs and bursts through a bedroom
door to find seek out with loaded Glock
9-millimeter handgun but they tackle
into the ground and disarm him safely
finally the police take him into custody
following his arrest officers located
several baggies of heroin and
methamphetamine the police action is to
round that fateful day are designed to
preserve life and in that respect
they're successful no citizen law
enforcement officer or seek at himself
is seriously injured or killed as a
result of the incident oh and the pups
are okay
shaken dirty but alive as for the lake
house well that's a different story by
the end of the incident the lake house
looks like it was bombed giant holes
riddled the outside of the lake house
including the burst frames of nearly
every window and doorway the interior of
the house is a swamp of debris from the
battering rams and explosives in fact
inspectors declare that the lake home is
uninhabitable and a danger to anyone who
enters however after the shocking
incident concludes the police contact
John liked to let him know that he and
his family can return to their home to
pick up some of their belongings the
officer also mentions that there was and
I quote some damage to the house de luxe
later described the scene as a war zone
when the Lexx arrived to the disaster
area that was once there lovely family
home their reaction is beyond distressed
their hearts sink the scene is so bad
that there aren't even any personal
belongings to pick up they've all been
destroyed and despite the fact the
police told the family they could return
to their property when they try to enter
the home they are unbelievably
threatened with arrest the city of
Greenwood Village has condemned the
residence as completely uninhabitable
and too dangerous for entry so now what
where can they go the likes aren't
millionaires they have one house their
most prized possession which has barely
been left standing so the Lexx appeal to
the police for help as they have nowhere
to go no clothes no personal items and
no home to sleep in that night in
response the police offer the family
exactly five thousand dollars according
to the police
five grand should cover everything
including their insurance deductible but
while the police are confident that the
five thousand dollars will cover a few
weeks worth of needs for the adults the
boy and two dogs who have nothing need
food shelter transportation
and clothing and all the other normal
items of daily activities the reality is
much different and although the city
assists the Lexx with temporary living
expenses in a gesture of good faith no
further crisis aid or help finding new
housing is offered
moreover the police deny any wrongdoing
liability or responsibility for the Lexx
damages the lek home has to be
demolished and rebuilt because it's
declared a total loss
sadly the house is torn down and what's
even worse for the Lexx is that a
precious heirloom ring one that survived
World War two in Italy is never
recovered from the house and the young
son has to move to another school
because the temporary housing they have
is out of his district
meanwhile the poor dogs are shaken to
the core in addition to being covered in
tear gas and explosive residue
so the traumatized pups are forced to
undergo medical exams deep cleaning in
the hair shaving on the brighter side a
dangerous criminal Robert C cat is in
jail and no longer a threat to society
he's convicted of nine counts of attempt
to commit manslaughter with a deadly
weapon against a peace officer two
counts of attempt to commit manslaughter
with a deadly weapon and several other
felonies he's sentenced to decades in
prison even so the luck family suffers
emotional pain and a severe disruption
to their lives as a result of the sudden
and disastrous loss of their home the
days and weeks that follow are daunting
and stressful especially for parents
trying to provide a young child with
physical and emotional security still
neither the police nor the village
offers further support of any kind
beyond the insufficient $5,000 enraged
by the entire incident and the damage
that's been done to their family along
with apathetic handling of the matter by
police in the city of Greenwood Village
the family decides to hire a lawyer in
Sioux miss Rachel Maxim and her team of
attorneys take the case the city and
police department are promptly served
with a summons and complaint leading
them to immediately engage Council of
their own
the police chief commander Varney and
all of the other police officers
involved in the incident are named as
defendants
so the proceedings begin
it's a contentious fight with the
tensions running high the Lexx file a
complaint alleging a violation of the US
Constitution's taking clause the takings
Clause of the Fifth Amendment requires
the government to pay just compensation
to property owners anytime their land or
other property is quote taken by the
state in other words their lawsuit
claims that says the government entity
took their home away from them it was a
matter of eminent domain which requires
the city to pay compensation for the
entire property loss the city and the
police however argue that there's a
distinction between a regulatory taking
where the government restricts your
property owners ability to use their
land by process of eminent domain and
the state's use of police power to
protect the public at trial the Lexx
lose on summary judgment which means
that even if the court assumes all of
their facts to be true
it doesn't amount to a recognized legal
claim therefore the case is dismissed
summarily without a full trial in
response the Lexx fight back and take
the case all the way up to the appellate
court the Tenth Circuit which hears the
case in the winter of 2018 will the
appellate judges see the case
differently than the trial judge let's
take a listen to the legal arguments
from both sides
good afternoon councillors so I have
here that this case is before the court
on the issue of whether the defendants
complete destruction of the plaintiffs
home and property is legally actionable
counselors please state your names for
the record and confirm that you're in
agreement that the issue is just as I
have stated thank you justice
Rachel Maxim for the plaintiff appellant
and yes that is the correct issue Andrew
Nathan on behalf of the defendants
appellees and we also agree with that
statement of the issue wonderful then
miss Maxim please proceed thank you
simply put the Lexx are seeking deserved
compensation for the loss of their
entire home
the police destroyed their house for no
good reason yes a felon must be captured
but not by blowing up innocent citizens
homes it's patently unjust thus the
defendants must provide fair
compensation to the Lac family may I
give a brief response to counsels
opening submission all right but keep it
short this case goes beyond mere
arguments to
appeal to emotions we have laws to
consider to uphold in this case the
police and state needed their rightful
immunity from prosecution to be able to
do the very job of capturing a man who
posed a danger to society well then
let's get on to the applicable law the
written briefs focus on the
Constitution's Fifth Amendment's takings
clause so let's hear your oral arguments
on that miss maxim justices we submit
that the trial court erred in its
interpretation of the takings clause the
doctrine of eminent domain for which the
takings Clause stands applies to the
Lexus case because their home was in
effect taken by a governmental entity
without their consent
thus the defendants must provide just
compensation to the legs but the trial
court found that eminent domain only
applies when the government takes legal
title and ownership of a private
citizens real property how was it
mistaken on that finding because the
court arbitrarily drew a hard line
between the government's power of
eminent domain and a state's police
power but there was no statutory or case
law to support such a distinction so
tell us what you think is the law on the
difference between state's police power
and the power of eminent domain if you
find any difference at all I submit that
the law permits application of logic and
common sense and that means the courts
must look at the ultimate predicament
into which the Lexx were put in order to
decide whether the preposterous acts and
massive destruction done by the
defendants are a taking so are you
saying that the purpose of the taking is
what makes the takings Clause apply and
not the definition of taking itself
exactly just as the US Army could take
over an entire neighborhood of homes
because that spot is needed for
strategic missile placement in order to
defend national security the lexis home
was taken over as the place where the
police needed to catch a dangerous
criminal in the interest of local
security what do you have to say about
that argument mr. nathen may it please
the court I find it's wholly unsupported
by case law counsel conveniently leaves
out the line of cases relied upon by the
trial court which clearly separate
eminent domain from police power counsel
fails to provide any authority that
stipulates the circumstances of the
taking
itself are the controlling factor we
must focus on the legal meaning of
taking if that's the case how should the
court define taking simply the way it's
defined by law and in layman's English
when something is removed from one
person by another and when it's then
retained by the second person here the
state never retained the property they
only use the lek home temporarily for
the public good the property has been
owned by the Lexx since the date of the
event that's nonsense your honors we
must remember that this was the Lexus
home their residents the place which
provided them shelter and for a good 19
hours they were homeless homeless is
homeless whether the property was
transferred to the police as temporary
or permanent owners or not the Lexx were
literally prevented from stepping foot
back into the home because it was
declared unsafe and uninhabitable if
that's not the police taking I don't
know what is mr. nathen how is this case
not one in which the plaintiffs lost use
of their home just like they would if
its title were transferred away from
them with all due respect justice
it doesn't matter why because this case
involved action by the state's police
power it was not a federal matter of
national security or any other power
that could lead to a commandeering of a
private party's property the police
power comes with its own rules apart
from the takings Clause please explain
the main relevant difference for the
case that bar police power controls the
use of property by the owner for the
public good authorizing its regulation
and destruction without compensation on
the other hand eminent domain takes
property for the public use and
compensation is given for the property
taken damaged or destroyed ms maxim is
mr. Nathan correct that takings under
police power do not require compensation
to the owner yes justice but I submit
that counsel is misleading the court
what I mean to say is that this case is
not about the difference between eminent
domain and the police power they are
different in this case the police
destroyed the house to protect the
public from a dangerous person benefit
the public the circumstances that led to
the destruction of my clients home fall
under the takings clause which means
that they're entitled to compensation
for its loss please clarify whether you
have any legal support for that position
because so far we've only heard your and
mr. Nathan's personal definitions of
taking I'm citing a federal court case
from 2017 in which the court clarifies a
distinction which is controlling here
that court found that when property is
damaged as a result of exercise of
police power it is not a taking for the
public use because the property has and
this is the key part the property has
not been altered thus if the property is
altered it logically follows that the
damage falls under the takings clause
thank you Miss Maksim do you mr. Nathan
have any cases you'd like to cite to
dispute that argument well all of the
cases which I cited in my written brief
to the court undermined that argument
but to be specific about the case miss
Maxim is referring to that court took
the words not been altered to mean its
purpose had not been altered to put it
another way had not been altered meant
not been changed in purpose to something
other than a private residential home
for example had not been altered to
become a blood drive facility or missile
command station any rebuttal our closing
miss maxim your the appellant Thank You
Justice I'd request that the court read
the reference case on its own and see
for itself what the 2017 Court meant by
the words in general though this is a
case where the police used my clients
home to conduct police business thus it
was taken out of my clients possession
completely taken away by its total
destruction
its purpose altered and thus having been
used in such a way it by definition
falls under the takings clause and this
Court should reverse the trial court's
dismissal thank you for your time
all right thank you Miss maksim Court is
adjourned
so what are your thoughts if you were
the judge what would you decide should
the police have to compensate the
homeowner for the total destruction of
the property resulting from the police
work that necessitated the damage pause
this video and let me know how you think
this should turn out I'll be right here
well the appellate court decided in
favor of the police thus it decided that
there is not a right to compensation
when the damage occurs as a result of
the state's police power and that the
demise the Lex home did not amount to a
taking the doctrine of eminent domain
did not apply insurance paid the Lex
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
less than half of what it cost to
actually repair the house and paid
nothing for the Lex legal fees but the
local government complained that the Lex
replaced their house in a way that was
much nicer than it was before the police
blew it up so take that as you will and
the Lex have asked the entire Tenth
Circuit Court of Appeals to reconsider
the panel decision if the Tenth Circuit
rules against them the Lex might take
their case all the way up to the US
Supreme Court that remains to be seen
do you think it's worth it for them to
try again hopefully the Lex will get
justice because that's what this channel
is all about but it can be hard to get
the word out on YouTube when dealing
with sensitive subjects because the only
thing scarier than getting your house
blown up by the police is getting
demonetised
which is why my Creator friends and I
teamed up to build our own platform
where creators don't need to worry about
D monetization or the dreaded algorithm
it's called nebula and we're thrilled to
be partnering with curiosity street
nebula is a place where creators can do
what they do best create it's a place
where we can both house our content ad
free and also experiment with original
content a new series that probably
wouldn't work on YouTube in fact if you
liked this episode of the case of you
can find an extended version that I
actually can't show on YouTube it's
legal eagle
now with 10% more explosions nebula
features a lot of YouTube's top
educational issue creators like Thomas
Frank Patrick Williams real engineering
tears ooh and tons of others we also get
to collaborate in ways that wouldn't
work on YouTube like Tom Scott's amazing
game show money where he pits a bunch of
famous youtubers against each other in
psychological experiments where they can
work together or profit individually it
is so so good so what does this have to
do with curiosity's dream well as the
go-to source for the best documentaries
on the internet they love educational
content and educational creators and we
worked out a deal where if you sign up
for curiosity stream with a link in the
description not only will you get a
one-month free trial for curiosity
stream you'll also get a nebula
subscription for free and to be clear
that nebula subscription is not a trial
it's free for as long as you are a
curiosity stream member and for a
limited time curiosity stream is
offering their documentary distancing
discount which gives you 40% off of
their annual plans and gift cards so you
can stay in and stay curious that's 12
dollars a year for both curiosity stream
and nebula I mean since we've got to
stay inside anyway we might as well be
soothed by the voice of David
Attenborough narrating tales about tiny
hummingbirds are join astronaut Chris
Hadfield on a road trip through the
universe or watch Tom Scott torture your
favorite youtubers so if you click on
the link in the description you'll get
both curiosity stream and nebula for 40%
off or you can go straight to curiosity
stream comm slash legal eagle it's a
great way to support this channel and
educational content directly for just
$12 per year just click on the link in
the description or again go to curiosity
scream comm slash legal eagle clicking
on the link in the description really
helps out this channel so how would you
have decided the case of the house the
police blew up leave your objections in
the comments and check out this playlist
over here with all of my other true
crime videos so to click on this video
and I'll see you in court